hey guys it is December the 17th today
my name is Jess McDonald and you're
watching games what news Dragon Age
Inquisition is getting a free and paid
DLC pack and here's what you can expect
the paid DLC pack is an expansion called
the deluxe upgrade and contains all the
content that was originally given to
players who bought the deluxe edition of
the game if you choose to walk out 10
bucks you can get hold of new armor
weapons melts and the sweet new fancy
looking throne theme to show everyone
what I'm awesome badass Inquisitor you
are if you prefer your expansions for
the price of three you can pick up the
destruction pack for dragon ages
multiplayer mode as Bioware describes it
destruction adds new paths to existing
destinations the conflicts raging
through the world has upset the balance
of nature wild creatures now ruined the
battlefield introducing chaos as they
attack both friend and foe both packs
are available today across all platforms
it seems that red dead redemption to
could really be a thing that you get to
look forward to rockstar answered a
question about a potential sequel to the
open-world western game in a Q&A on
their blog by saying as we've mentioned
when asked in the past about new games
in other series such as red dead
redemption bully and LA Noire we don't
always rush to make sequels but that
does not mean we won't get to them
eventually the developer suggested that
fans should stay tuned next year for
potential news on said hypothetical
sequels 2010's red dead redemption was
crazy popular selling 13 million copies
so a sequel seems like a good idea for
the dev and fans alike controversial
shooter hatred is back on Steam having
been reinstated by gabe newell himself
the massacre simulator which was pulled
from steam greenlight a little over a
day ago is now back up on the platform
gabe newell wrote to develop a
destructive creation saying that it was
not a good decision to pull the game he
expressed his apologies and noted that
the situation would be rectified you all
didn't specifically address why valve
decided to pull it in
place or why he overturned the call
answer your question of the day let me
know what your theory on this situation
is if you're after more news you can
head to gains but we've got stories on
lords of the fallen to an assassin's
creed unity has a bunch more problems
that is it for me today thanks for
sticking around and be sure to stay
tuned for more news things tomorrow